welcome to Hannity tonight more positive
statistics from this country's fight
against covin 19 plus more bold action
from the president this time against the
China centric World Health Organization
we have an update we'll break down the
details for you also Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo fascinating information that
they have released from the State
Department we'll ask him about it also
with just two hundred and three days
till Election Day and you we the people
you're the ultimate jury Oh
quid pro quo Joe he ever confused one
finally got the endorsements he's
anxiously been waiting for in the middle
of a pandemic and national emergency and
after every single other Democratic
candidate dropped out and even after yep
Bernie Sanders finally announced the the
support of the presumptive nominee yeah
finally we hear from him
President Obama stepped up today and
finally managed to release an Internet
video kind of week offering support for
his former vice president okay the
question for me is why why this way why
in the middle of a national emergency in
pandemic last one end and he finally
decided to endorse quid pro quo Joe
maybe he didn't want anyone to hear it
after all if anyone knows that Joe
doesn't have a fastball or even a slow
pitch it has to be Obama he knows the
truth and get this during his glowing
endorsement Obama call Biden the most
progressive candidate in history and he
can't get Fox News out of his head he
can't we live in his mind he takes a
shot at Fox again me little yours truly
I live in his mind I don't know how why
but take a look I'm so proud to endorse
Joe Biden for President of the United
States
choosing Joe to be my vice president was
one of the best decisions I ever made
Joe already has what is the most
progressive platform of any major Party
nominee in history our country's future
hangs on this election and it won't be
easy the other side has a massive war
chest the other side has a propaganda
network with little regard for the truth
you're not talking about the real
propaganda networks we've been saying
this for months there are no more
moderates inside the car
party he's acknowledging it radical
group extreme socialist Democrats that
have fully adopted the madness of green
New Deal policies from the radical left
now we got the ever confused Joe Biden
is the leader of this extreme socialist
party running on a platform that even
Bolshevik Bernie is kind of proud of him
by the way even in the middle of a
global pandemic former President Obama
look at that he can't stop attacking Fox
News after all these years we are alive
and well in his mind and for some reason
he never liked me just a quick reminder
in history lesson in 2012 Latinos voted
to record numbers
the next day even Sean Hannity changed
his mind and decided immigration reform
was a good idea Rudy Giuliani said Putin
is what you call a leader Mike Huckabee
and Sean Hannity keep talking about his
bare chest which is kind of weird with
respect to Sean Hannity I didn't know
that he had invited me for a beer his
opinion of me does not seem to be very
high but but I'm always good for a beer
I'll pit I'll put out put mr. Burgess up
against Sean Hannity he'll tear them up
I'm sure I'll have to pay for the beer
redistribution of wealth but he can
afford it the thing is is more energetic
in those videos than he was in this
online endorsement thing today and like
his devout followers and the medium mob
Obama come it's like we live in his head
this network we live in a lot of
people's heads we live in MSDN sees head
and fake news cnn's head because we're
the ones that dare to vet him and we'll
vet whoever is running it looks like
well the ever
well confused quid pro quo Joe super
Thursday and n1h one we're the only ones
that exposed we did a deep dive into the
radical hate preacher we were right
about Reverend Gd America Reverend right
we were the ones that exposed his ties
to Ayers and Dohrn or The Weather
Underground we were the ones that
exposed his lies about Obamacare Meah
millions of you lost you doctors lost
your plans and you're all
paying nearly 200 percent more and guess
what which is 203 days to go we are
going to be the only ones that vet the
ever confused quid pro quo Joe we will
hold him accountable for the horrific
obama-biden record let's see 8 years 13
million more Americans food stamps 8
million more poverty lowest labor
participation rate since the 70s
accumulated more debt than every other
administration before them combined and
lowest homeownership rate in 50 years
worse recovery since the 40's and for
the next 200 plus days we will continue
to call out yes the Democratic radical
socialist party their propaganda arm
which is the mainstream media mob and
including quid pro quo Joe's abuse of
power and yes his zero experience on
hunter that got filthy rich with no
experience and you you think that MSDN
see fake news CNN the New York Times
Washington Post you think they'll ever
bet Joe Biden no they protected him they
cared about quid pro quos but not with
Joe and Hunter they cared about
obstruction of justice but not Hillary's
emails they cared about Russian election
interference but not Hillary's bought
and paid for dirty dossier used to spy
on a presidential candidate deep into
his presidency we're getting to the
bottom of that their sole mission defeat
Donald Trump slander Donald Trump
besmirched Donald Trump same people even
in the middle of a national crisis a
pandemic health emergency the mob and
the media predictably cares about one
thing what they've cared about since
Donald Trump Melania Trump came down
that escalator in Trump Tower smearing
slandering the President of the United
States I have said it if he cured cancer
they wouldn't they want to impeach him
for curing cancer but for the first time
in years we have a president not afraid
to fight back and he does it well with
some power and gusto and energy Joe can
use some energy take a look we have a
few clips that we're just going to put
up we could turn the lights a little bit
lower I think you'll find them
interesting we will be suspending
Travel from Europe to the United States
for the next 30 days to unleash the full
power of the federal government of this
effort today I am officially declaring a
national emergency we could give you
hundreds of clips just like that we have
them we didn't want this to go on too
long but I just want to say it's you
know it's very sad when people write
false stories we did all of this work
but when you read the phony stories you
know buddy nobody acknowledges this and
it doesn't have to be acknowledged from
my standpoint but it does have to be
acknowledged from the great work that
these doctors nurses the Army Corps of
Engineers Fame all these people they've
done this incredible job 90% of this
country have been amazing
corporations pharmaceutical companies
that we're trained to hate Walmart we're
supposed to not like Walmart all these
companies all-hands-on-deck the nurses
the doctors the researchers the
scientists we have seen the absolute
best in America during a really
difficult time there are exceptions the
predictable people the mob and the media
Trump could do nothing right
if they can't intellectually be honest
enough to say you know what in
retrospect that xenophobic hysterical
fear-mongering travel ban and quarantine
first time in 50 years and subsequent
travel bans Wow how many Americans
didn't contract that disease how many
Americans exponentially didn't die how
much worse would this beef they can't
admit that then you know where they're
coming from but that's the mob in the
media that is the Democratic Party
they're working on an investigation
shift another shift show in the middle
of a national emergency
oh and he wants the media to stop
covering in the middle of a national
emergency news and information coming
from the president pretty sick but
predictable for them by the way know
everything they're seeing is through the
20/20 prism for them it's about two
hundred and three days all politics
their rage against the president is so
extreme so hateful so psychotic I've
been saying for three years they're
hurting our country they don't care
not the travel bans not the quarantine
they won't give this president this is
the greatest medical mobilization in the
history of mankind we rose to the
occasion because of the greatness the
goodness the American people and yep the
leadership of the president the vice
president their Task Force and others
too a lot of Governors did well here now
I've said it many many times the media
in America it's a disservice irreparable
damage forget about their own reputation
they could never get a back